well when we filmed the special we were
still together so you know it's just a
matter of the relationship didn't work
out we both went our separate ways and
that's okay too you know there's a
little thing at the end of the special
that speaks to that you know I had kind
of lost my faith in men and you know I
then I got into a relationship and I
that that Faith was renewed and it made
me open-minded and open-hearted and I
remained that way and so I'm grateful
for that time together and I I'm glad
that we did that special together it was
a great experience yeah have you guys
had a chance to celebrate the success of
the special have you talked yeah we
haven't celebrated no I mean I've been
in Whistler I've been skiing I like to
focus on skiing in the winter living
your best life yeah I'm trying to get
into the elderly Olympics in about 10
years so how's that going it's going
well actually I'm really thriving you do
say at the end of the special you have
that beautiful banner that comes across
the screen I loved it I wrote it down it
says I still believe in love and I now
know more than ever that my person is
coming so easy to close yourself off
after going going through something you
know hard like that yeah but you went
the opposite way why do you think that
is because I believe in love and I love
the way that you know love can light you
up and how then and the togetherness I
mean I was single like for so long and
so annoyed by the idea of someone in my
space or in my bed right or away in
between me and my dogs I want to sleep
with my dogs you know what I mean I want
my dog on top of me when I sleep at
night and then I want to throw him away
from me when I get too hot but I want
like I love Independence I love being
able to get up in the morning and fly to
a different country I and I do do that I
have done that and so the idea that
somebody there's an attachment always
looked at me like a weight around you
know like an albatross and uh so I think
what I learned from the last
relationship is that you know that's
okay I didn't I didn't hate that I liked
the togetherness and I liked the
constant camaraderie and having a buddy
and I just thought oh yeah you can find
somebody that you have a lot in common
with and and and that can work as well
you know it's not the end-all be-all but
it's also it can be beautiful as long as
you are really like delivering up your
best self in that relationship you don't
want to ever have to be anybody that
you're not you know what I mean thousand
percent and every everybody has the
ability to make other people be better
and be stronger
um so yeah I I mean I'm definitely open
to it I love love and I love that you
said in that statement that you you
think you will find your person how are
we doing on that oh yeah we're doing
we're doing okay we're doing okay yeah
okay yeah and anything I have nothing to
announce okay I mean I'm pregnant but
other than that I have nothing to
announce the puppy so I mean we'll have
to find out who the father is for that
the 47 year old comedian is gearing up
for a big year romantically and
professionally she's hosting the Critics
Choice Awards this Sunday and she's
guest hosting the Daily Show next month
with an eye on filling the seat
permanently hosting the Daily Show
hosting the Daily Show is this a gig
that you're gunning for to be permanent
or would you like to shift back and to
maybe explore a Chelsea talk show
um I mean I'm open to everything at this
point I realized when I hosted Jimmy
Kimmel last year I can say last year an
hour yeah I realized you know that gave
me kind of the the uh zest that I used
to have when the beginning of Chelsea
Lately the first five or six years I
loved it and um and I remembered like I
especially commenting and regurgitating
everything that happens in the news and
being able to comment on that that's
kind of my gig with your perspective yes
and I like it and it's kind of what I do
best and so I'm definitely open to all
sorts of possibilities on that front I
mean I'm gonna go host the guest host
The Daily Show for a week and we'll see
you know what happens from that and
we're in discussions about all sorts of
things you know I don't know if you know
this but it's been nearly 10 years since
Chelsea Lately wrapped up it has it
almost 10 years 2024 I will Mark will
Mark the 10 years and the idea of
revisiting a Chelsea Handler talk show I
imagine 10 years later would look a
little different what what do you think
that show would look like in 2023 I
think it would just be a little bit more
elevated you know the subject matter
it's not just celebrity gossip I don't
think that's that's never that has
that's the reason I stopped doing that
show I wasn't interested in discussing
that anymore I I mean I like it a little
bit to a degree but it can't be the
whole breadth of the show there's room
for news there's room for politics
there's room for like social issues and
you know and human interest stories and
there's room for commentary on all of
those things so I think I would desire a
more well-rounded show is there anything
from the original show that you're like
I'm gonna leave that in the past we are
definitely not bringing that into
anything new that we do well I don't
think I mean we're not going to be
making fun of celebrities anymore I mean
you know people like Kanye and Elon Musk
deserve it but you know not people like
Britney Spears and Lindsay Lohan like
that was just not I wouldn't do that
again you know that was old times and
old me and and it just doesn't really
benefit anybody so I think we've all you
know there's an evolution or a
revolution there's all of these things
that happening are happening and I kind
of like the new parameters I like not
being able to make fun of people and and
have to come up with more clever jokes
I'm interested in being challenged like
that what is it going to take
um well they're gonna have to find me a
chewy doppelganger or somebody and there
is no such thing because he was a one in
a million Chuy Bravo Chelsea's longtime
sidekick passed away in 2019. so while
her talk show future remains up in the
air she's focused on her special
Revolution out now on Netflix Chelsea
jokes about everything from giving up
her rescue dog I found him his forever
home that's how I look at that story
to her thoughts on motherhood say I
don't want to be a mother but I wouldn't
mind being like a divorced dad you know
I could crush that roll coming in hot at
like 50 all the time
is there ever anything off limits I mean
I try not to make fun of children
because I don't love them you know and
but I try not to go in on them I just
talk about my experience and why it's
not that I dislike children I don't want
to make fun of children you know what I
mean but I wanna I wanna Empower all the
people that feel the way that I do about
owning the fact that you're not
interested in being a mom and that
you're not interested necessarily in
marriage and that you can be happy and
have this wonderful life without those
things and that societal pressure is
nonsense so I like to I'd like to take
or I take a lot of pride in representing
that group of people who does feel the
pressure who do feel like oh my God I'm
not worth it or I'm not worth anything
until I get married and I think the
message in the special because there are
many messages but the overall theme is
to own yourself I talk about in the
special very you know for a long time
about how I'm fully aware that I don't
have the capability abilities to be a
parent and that is a very important
thing to recognize about yourself
self-awareness there's a lot of people
out there that have babies that
shouldn't be having babies and when you
know enough about yourself I know that
I've parented my two dogs I've parented
several dogs which I discuss in the
special and I can tell based on that
parenting that I shouldn't take it any
further what has the feedback been the
reaction that you've seen from fans it's
been great I mean it's been great to see
it and and it's kind of like a dream
come true in a way I mean I've done
stand-up for so long but the way this
special looks and the way that I look
and the and the clarity and the joke
telling like I'm very proud of it and uh
it was just it was just been a great
experience to kind of come back to stand
up I um I did a special couple years ago
but I had taken the time off from doing
stand up until I really had something to
say and had you know and I'm a
Storyteller I just like telling my
personal stories and sharing my
embarrassing moment my most embarrassing
moments so when people respond like oh
my God that's happened to me this I did
that I did that then you know you know
you're hitting a nice cord
[Music]